Peggy's 16 hey everyone it's dan Mar
here with our first part of a guide to
battlefield fives classes and combat
roles I'm joined here by battlefield
expert study thank you for joining me
hi there alright yeah I'm very well
thank you in this first video we're
going to be discussing the assault and
medic classes and talking about the
combat roles for both
so let's kick things off with what I
imagine will be a very popular choice
for the novice gamer and that's the
assault class and the light infantry
combat role so the light infantry is an
aggressive infantry class more balanced
for killing other infantry so you've got
the scavenger trait which means whenever
you kill an enemy soldier and you pick
up their ammo it'll give you more ammo
than it with the normal soldier and then
you've also got a slightly more health
regen so you get 10 extra health on top
of the 30 that you get that's just a
standard soldier so you're a bit more
beefy and you want to be getting in
there and you know using the really fast
fire rate weapons so that you know you
can keep up with the people at close
range so you can soak up a little more
damage and maybe even act a little bit
as bait for people who may be a slightly
further away with the the Recon class
absolutely so you don't have more health
but you get more health regen back when
you actually do regen your health so it
just gives you a little bit of an
advantage in closable situations
basically
okay so the second combat role for the
assault class is the vehicle Buster how
does this differ to light infantry them
so you're much more focused on trying to
destroy vehicles on the map and the
traits that you get mean that you're a
lot better at doing so the reason why
you take this class is you get a vehicle
painter trait which means that as soon
as you damage a vehicle it instantly
becomes spotted for your entire team so
you can't use normal weapons you have to
use explosives it has to be a bit
explosive damage so your grenades your
dynamite your rocket launches anything
like that and then it also gives you
extra requisition points to actually
help you get squad perks so you can call
in squad things like the v1 rocket or
another tank so destroying vehicles
gives your squad more opportunities to
get better things to win the game so
that can kind of snowball I guess you
know you from that initial sort of tank
Buster you can then just build your
entire team it's just a vehicle
annihilating powerhouse absolutely so
it's okay it's a passive role to gain
more advantages for your team
okay so let's move away from assault and
let's get into the the medic class first
up the combat medic role talk us through
this one tom
so the combat medic role is more focused
on aggressive infantry play so similar
to the light infantry but you're much
more of a utility unit as well so you're
still healing and reviving people so
with the combat medic you get longer
reach with melee weapons which means
that you can actually hit them before
they can hit you even if they swing for
you and you also get a faster sprint
when it critical health so when you've
lost a lot of health you can quickly
dart away and hopefully dodge bullets
before you get hit again
and finally for this video we're going
to look at the other medic combat role
and that is the field medic so this is
more of a passive role so with this
class you get additional squad points
for giving your squad bandages so the
more you heal them the more chance you
get for giving an advantage to your
squad like a v1 a tank or supplies and
then you also sprint faster when calling
out to a downed friend so when you see a
teammate that's down on the floor you'll
actually run over to them faster when
you spot them so that's it for the first
part of our guide to Battlefield fives
classes and combat roles study thank you
so much for your insight and expertise
look out for the next video soon or
we'll be covering the support and recon
roles
play it on the world's most powerful
console
[Music]